مضى عمان على رئاسه تشبه بيدن للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمؤشر الاهم على فشله
او نجاحه هو استطلاعات الراي اخر رؤيه
تشير الى
55% من الامريكيين يعارضون سياسات الرئيس
الامريكي علما انه قدم لهم بعض الانجازات
فهو واجه التضخم الذي وصل الى اكثر من 10%
وتمكن من تخطي الازمه من دون الدخول في
ازمه اقتصاديه اوليه كما انه اظهر الى
الامريكيين انه يهتم بهم من خلال الجايحه
لكن الالاف ماتوا في عهده
[موسيقى]
انت غبيا حقق مع الحزب الديمقراطي انتصارا
في الانتخابات النصفيه عند محتفظوا مجلس
الشيوخ
في من تزعل الجمهوريون مجلس النواب
وسيستعملونه لمحاسبته مشاكل بيضا فضيحه
الوثائق السريه التي اكتشفها المحامون في
مكتبه وبيته وهي تعادل فضيحه وثائق الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لكننا لم نرى بعد
تاثير هذه القضيه على شعبيه بيضا
اما في عشان الخارجي فاسرع بيضا للانسحاب
من افغانستان
بقيت صادمه للراي العام
دوليا
في مواجهه روسيا لكنه النجاح في ابقاء
الجنود الامريكيين خارج المعركه وتحاشى
مواجهه مباشره مع روسيا
الانجاز والاهم لدى بايدن خلال العامين
وهو ترميم العلاقات الامريكيه مع
المجموعات الدوليه بدءا من الناتو
والاتحاد الاوروبي ويعمل الان على ترميم
العلاقات مع افريقيا وينظم مواجهه الصين
اقتصاديا وعسكريا بالتعاون مع استراليا
واليابان والهند فشل حتى الان في العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي مع ايران واعاد مبدا
حل الدولتان لحل الصراع الاسرائيلي
الفلسطيني وما زال في الخطوات الاولى
هناك صوره ثانيه للرئيس بيضا الصوره
الاولى هي صوره رئيس اكبر دوله في العالم
اقتصاديا وعسكريا وسوره الرئيس المتلعثم
في الكلام
اذا ما كان سيترشح في مواجهه دونالد ترامب
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله